There are some efforts right now to
try to de extinct some animals there.
Thank you. Yeah, you mean that
one new word and a w like what is,
what is currently going on right now?
They're calling it the dawn
of de extinction and it's um,
it's a lot of very,
very intelligent genetic scientists that
are trying to isolate specific genes
that are specific to the animals that
have been extinct and putting them into
extent animals,
animals that are still here to basically
make this Frankenstein animal because
it will never be the animal that's gone.
Right.
It will look like it'll behave like
it will think like it, et Cetera,
but it will never actually be the animal
that we've lost. At least not yet.
We haven't,
we don't have that technology right now.
What we can do is isolate a genome,
put it into an existing animal that gives
birth to an animal that looks and acts
very much like the extinct down,
but it's some degree different because
it's like part like of a mammoth.
For instance, they would have to
take some DNA from a mammoth, right?
That they would somehow, or another
get and introduce it to an embryo,
but how much of an elephant and the
elephant would give birth to a very hairy,
very large Tusk,
like these isolated genetic codes,
elephant. And it would look like a
mammoth. It would act like a mammoth.
But the reality is it's a shaggy
elephant with big tusks. Right.
So if you did like 23 and
me on it, it would show, oh,
it's mostly LF. Exactly. That's a
little bit of a mammoth. Yeah. I mean,
if you think of a double helix,
like a DNA strand, right?
You have these little bars in the
middle of it. So what they do is,
this is a very crude way to explain it,
but they pull out a bar from an
elephant and they put in a bar from, um,
a mammoth and then eventually
you get this mammoth.
And so this would be like gene
editing tools like crisper. Exactly.
On those lines. Exactly. Wow. And so
how far away are they from doing this?
Uh, it's, I mean, it's been successfully
done a couple of times. They've, Yup.
They've given birth to a couple
of animals that are very,
very close to the extinct animal. Most
of the time there's problems, right?
There's, it's in fertile, it's a,
it has lung issues, whatever it is.
There's a couple of different cases.
I'm not a geneticist,
I'm a wildlife biologist so I don't
really understand it, but it's,
they've done it.
They have successfully reproduce things
that are gone basically clone things and
then the animal hasn't made it to
adulthood. Man, that seems really,
really like playing. God does. It is,
it is absolutely like playing God.
I feel like, I mean is are people
doing it just cause they can,
is it one of those things or a zero,
like a real valid scientific reason for
trying to reintroduce these animals are
d extinct them? Well, the,
the valid reason is to
conserve the ecosystem, right?
Like we talked about,
but I think it goes back to what we
were saying half an hour ago, which is,
it's just that that quest for knowledge
that can we do it, the innovation, right?
Can we play God, can we fix it? Can we
take this thing that's gone and say no,
not like we have the tools to make
it not gone. Yeah. There was um,
some article that I read where they were
talking about reintroducing the mammoth
to Siberia and that there would be some
ecological benefit to reintroducing the
mammoth because of the way
they forage for food. Sure.
They would have some sort of an effect
on global warming. Sure. Which I mean,
do you know about that?
I don't know about that specifically.
You could find that Jamie,
the reintroducing the mammoth to
Siberia to benefit the environment.
Look whether that's accurate or not
until you put mammoths on the ground,
how do we actually know it's a great
theory and that's what science is, right?
It's coming up with hypothesis and then
trying to prove them and it sounds cool.
Like, do I want to see a mammoth
walking around Siberia? Fuck yeah.
But does that mean it's actually good
for the world? Hard to say. Whoa.
Could bringing back mammas
help stop climate change?
Scientists say creating hybrids of extinct
bees could fix the Arctic Tundra and
stop greenhouse gas emissions.
I don't understand that.
I find it hard to believe,
to be honest.
Maybe it's just some scientists clever
way of sneaking it in because he wants to
play God like, Hey, we're going to fix
everything. Yeah. Fucking use coal.
Who gives a shit? Yeah. Hamets we got
Matt. Just give me the funding clean,
man. That's, that's sadly
very real. Well, is it really?
Oh yeah. I mean, look, if you're
a scientist, right? Right. You,
Joe Rogan is a scientist.
How are you going to make your career?
Are you going to make your
career by raising money
through being like, yeah, sure.
Like I'll study cricket legs,
or you going to be like, look,
give me the money to stop global warming
by bringing back fucking mammas like,
right.
You know,
like why you can make the outrageous
claim if you think it's going to fund your
research. Right. That's how you
make your bones. Right. And that's,
that's one of the sad realities of some,
certainly not all science.